doesn't
mean UK law is not based on religion
what I'm saying Britain by the way when
I criticize Britain a mod Britain that
has lot of good you understand like for
example us say the best country for the
Muslims in the Western World I believe
is Britain Allah teach me to be just
okay so I'm not going to be rude I'm not
going to deny a country that been good
to me as well but we have to speak the
truth so Britain is still country which
is based upon Christianity
okay every country in the Western World
France Britain Germany Holland by the
way these countries came to Africa
France came to my country and forced
Christianity on us they start turning
our M to churches okay and guess what go
to France now you can insult Jesus our
beloved Messiah you can insult him you
can even draw him and unate with but I
dare you if you rate on a gay flag so in
the Christianity and gay people but you
Jesus would lgbtq but guess what in the
Western World lgbtq there are more
honorable more respected than our
Beloved the best man that W upon the
face of the Earth after the prophet
Muhammad the prophet is been
disrespected come on bro that's why you
know's what's
with you should ask no ask what is right
with them first what's wrong if you
don't know what me what's wrong it's
evil what they doing it's a sin
according to Islam teaching yes so is it
a
sin that's what Allah the Quran even the
Bible yes a major sin and by the way you
know Subhan
Allah last year I spoke to this a
Catholic Christian she left catholism
and she
wasan so I was giving her I was
preaching to her then she said you know
what you say makes sense but I have
something to ask I think okay she said
what do you about lgbtq I said there too
many letters to think of have to break
it one one I said look I'm not going to
water down my religion because to please
you I in Islam is it's forbidden but
that doesn't mean I should kill you or
fight you you understand so I speaking
to her breaking it down for her should
become Muslim I said to her look all of
us have our desires Islam can be Muslim
Muslim yeah no no no no no we can't say
she can be I'm just asking cannot be
Haram but what I'm saying we have our
own desires yes like for example our
desires
for example I'm going have desires to
rob people okay if you control it Allah
will reward you for it so that's why I
said to said don't sell your Eternal
Paradise for the sake of desires for 40
years see people having sex in a house
how is that harming anyone you see this
problem of and misunderstanding what is
a sin you think a sin if I'm doing a sin
and I'm not I'm not harming no one you
are harming God's law you are going
against God's law so basically if I'm
having intercourse with if someone
having intercourse with his own mother
in their own room they don't have no one
are they so is it
okay what mean you don't know
check you to ask me I mean any human
being with a sound reasoning he knows a
child having intercourse don't want is
the term CU sometimes children watch our
videos having intercourse with their own
mothers that is evil and you tell you
don't know if it's evil or
not I don't know I'm
not I don't know I've never met those of
people meting
oril it's
evil to me evil is if you harming
someone that's evil so if a man have
with own
I told you I told you Islam ISL ISL if
that
daughter but if the she's 40 years old
the okay basically yeah I don't care you
don't care no I don't care I to me for
me even someone if someone hatting
someone that's evil right intentionally
you you find someone weak or something
and you hurt them that's evil you need
to check your moral compass like you're
all over the place are you a
Christian what what believed
you you don't believe in
nothing that's why you confused confused
why do you think I'm confused anyone
watching Christian or a Muslim or Hindu
or sck they know you're confused because
anyone thinks it's okay or he says I
don't
know if a man sleeping with mother it's
evil agrees with this if you said yeah
no I never thought about it like you
brought that question to my question I
don't know never anyway so can so this
beautiful creation came like a randomly
to yeah it's random it's random so you
believe in a Creator so who created it
random so you believe in a Creator
random random yeah you random Creator so
logical rational watch this logical
rational Randomness is not a is not
being
is is an action based upon no choice so
how so the action even Randomness it
needs to do how Randomness is going to
create something Randomness doesn't not
exist
independently Randomness is an
expression of of an action that Ur
without
thinking yeah from
chaos yeah doesn't make any sense order
order order there's order there's order
there's order but there's also K in
order right no no there's no
no there is there's a book there's a
book who was written by Peter Atkins who
an atheist called seven rules okay he's
an aist he's a British aist okay and he
that book that he has written his
followers from the aist said to him you
are supporting the the by writing that
book and he was explaining cuz he's a
physicist everything's connected every's
old everything there's a p to follow you
understand for example regardless how
many times I'm going to F this cup in
the air it will never turn to
occur there's there's a part no follow
you understand so there's order okay so
my point here is you believe in a
Creator called Randomness you know why I
don't want to believe in a true creator
because by believe in a true creator you
have to follow his commandments so due
to your desires and arrogance you want
to look for any excuse to reject the
true creator and you accept the most
silly thing which you said Randomness
create this universe
life but it's by chance if you do some
so Universe by chance Define chance
there's a lot of the chance happens
random from so from 100 you might have
chance an chance is an how
cre from
explosion if you stud if you study the
star of how they explode what's going on
inside you go you'll find that okay yeah
you you go study how it STS okay explod
and how how the chem how chemical
interacts with each other what happens
okay how the soil is created or the
water then you you kind of get some sort
of idea how the world is created you see
why you're confusing it's not like I'm
asking you how between
how somebody sat there saying okay this
is to my question how you ask you how is
created I say who there between
who created and if you want random so
Randomness created Define random step
byep step by step step by step random
what is
Randomness
probability Randomness by chance
probability yeah so where's
probability from 100 there's a% chance
so probility create universe probility
is an expression how you create
Universe for example if I'm if I say for
example
that if
you you are given expression of
something that can occur you know what
he saying basically if someone ask who
creat you know some it's a concept if
you put four different cre without
looking you there's a problem coming up
you it's like someone said this is mypr
listen carefully you know what you're
doing it's like someone said to you who
created the universe you said 2 + 2 - 5
create the universe that's what you're
doing you think probability
expression expression probability is not
entity because okay can you create
something if you don't have the
ability that's probility has ability
ability the universe happen because of
because agree with me create
something like the life that you see we
see is created by just over time okay
all you said probility cre
Universe explanation you said there is
not a POS explanation how God created
the universe okay there is just say
question you should you should be more L
I think you should be you should accept
God create the universe you know why
because if you accept probability which
is I AC God allow me to allow me to
Finish First I'm tell you nothing
because if you brain already have the
capacity to accept probability create
the universe it is more so should have
capacity to accept God who possessed
knowledge and the power and ability to
create the universe it's more logical
for a being to have a
power finish all me to Finish First
allow me to finish that's why you confus
between how and who okay so if you
already accept probility probility is a
concept
correct does concept have ability
ability you smash there a probability of
I don't know how many smash that's
probability okay so probity is not
du I speak they will go off I don't let
you
speak again that's probability so so
probability is
do so probility is not
du so how you create the universe then
okay how start cre
about God un this
book this book which is I will give it
to you about eight ISM okay and you can
read how Allah cre the universe Allah
already explained to us in the Quran how
we create the universe first firstly
firstly firstly it's not about how okay
it's about who I'm talking about because
if you already for example if someone
accept this phone was created by a rock
then if I tell him this phone was
created by a doctor who has ability and
the knowledge and the wisdom and and and
everything he should accept it more
because a rock doesn't have ability
doesn't have a knowledge which requires
someone to create something so therefore
first thing you should ask me who is God
then I will answer to you Allah himself
with absolute power absolute knowledge
absolute wisdom absolute perfection soct
when you look at his creation you come
to conclusion
you can see the effect of God's
attribute within his creation power so
tremendous creation look how big it is
in the understand must be created by
someone who's more powerful subhah okay
so that's what ask me who is God so if I
said to you God who created this
universe have
ability has power has a knowledge has a
wisdom CU we can see this effect of this
attribute in the creation you have a
nose next to your mouth why
asking you what question no no why you
have your nose why your nose know next
to you I doesn't have anything because
before you smell food look look step by
step I know I know aist if you tell him
what is your mother's name he said my
father D Mercedes I'm not asking you
what yeah let me tell you okay that's
Allah in the Quran you know I like now
you said you never thought about it you
know what Allah in the Quran
within the creation there's a signs for
God's existence and should be wased
alone and within your soul we have a no
next to our mouth before you eat what
you do smell food you have eyebrows
above your eyes why because sweat
contains the Sal if it keeps going to
your eye will damage it so protect it
you have a liquid in your
eye I'm not say what caused it first
just look Evolution cannot do it again
does evolution has a power do Evolution
has a wisdom evolution of knowledge so
foret that that's what it's a process
talking about okay so my point it's not
caused it so again my point again look
at yourself you have a liquid in your
ears which is ther stop going into your
ears the liquid that you have in your
eyes thinner and if it goes in it come
take it out you have teeth in your mouth
before you eat what you do is True Food
you have your eyes above when you walk
you can see and you walk forward you
have a J in your elbows you give and you
take even within our body where the
heart is and the L and the lung and the
kidney everything is order and organized
it's impossible illogical irrational for
that to come without any Creator to
possess knowledge and a power and
ability
simple that what
name Iran my best friend from
Iran yeah I ask Allah to guide you TR in
read that book it's a nice book you come
here
often okay inah so that's why take
care guide stay in the